accused gunman Nicolas Cruz was in court
yesterday but he may not be back for a
while Cruz's public defender says the
suspect will probably not appear at
future hearings because there's no need
for it and well the hor cos is outside
the Broward County Jail where Cruz is
being held without bail and well good
morning good morning here's how it all
played out Cruz's defense attorneys
argued he should not be present in the
courtroom because it would create a
quote media circus but the judge ruled
against him saying that he should be
there the accused gunman showed up
dressed in a prison jumpsuit he stared
at the ground and spoke only briefly to
his lawyer the hearing focused on some
of the rules going forward and whether
documents including those about the
state welfare agencies past interactions
with Cruz should be made public also
yesterday Florida Governor Rick Scott
called on the FBI to release details
surrounding its failure to take action
after receiving a tip last month about
Cruz that tip described his alleged
erratic behavior desire to kill people
and potential to conduct a school
shooting the FBI tells CBS News it has
no comment on the governor's request CBS
News has also learned that over the last
year Cruz purchased at least seven
rifles his defense attorneys have said
he would plead guilty to 17 counts of
premeditated murder if the death penalty
is off the table but no decisions have
been made about that Gael
all right Manuel thank you very much